dans son bureau de vancouver janet une
chose ne voit pas les journées passent
et noé verte next week
après presque quatre mois d'inactivité
les plateaux de cinéma et de télévision
recommenceront bientôt à s'animer
le producteur est à pied d'oeuvre pour
préparer le redémarrage tant attendu on
va utiliser même temps mais on va rouler
moins pour donner le temps pour les
employés les artistes pour travailler
dans une environnement vraiment
sécuritaire
de concert avec l'industrie l' agence
provinciale de santé et sécurité au
travail a développé une série de
directives pour permettre la reprise des
tournages moins de techniciens seront
admis sur les plateaux et tous les
travailleurs devront autant que possible
resté à bonne distance les uns des
autres des défis particuliers pour une
industrie unique en son genre déjà
créatif les artisans devront réinventer
leur façon de faire souligne le syndicat
des techniciens de nouvelles méthodes
devenu essentiel mais plus coûteuses les
api sade ou les films qui ont un budget
large nos clients nos studios
il veut un homme vraiment vraiment
sécuritaire et ils vont donner un peu de
plus d'argent pour aider d'accord si les
petits producteurs pourraient avoir plus
de difficultés le secteur dans son
ensemble devrait malgré tout rester
rentables lui qui est un moteur
économique majeure en colombie
britannique rappelle la présidente cris
de ici lagence provincial de
développement du cinéma et de télévision
après l'interruption soudaine d'environ
40 production provoquées par la kfw 19
tout soit que les choses reviennent à la
normale dans ce qu'on a surnommée
l'allée web du nord la grande région de
vancouver pourraient même tirer un
avantage de la situation stable en
colombie britannique
de l'avis de tous le monde du cinéma et
des thés division devra constamment
s'adapter à la nouvelle réalité du corps
anna virus john henshaw lui se croisent
les doigts pour que les contraintes qui
y sont reliés ne se reflète pas trop à
l'écran mais on espère de donner à nos
clients et nos ânes aux audiences à les
épisodes
tu vois pas de camp coved quand ils
voient mais on sert messi est ici
mathieu cueillez radio canada vancouver